[Applaudissements]
ça
jamais plus en plus belle
alors c'est ma conseillère aussi de
campagne voilà un type et allez vous
voir deux fois en spectacle et il n'a
pas payé
écoutez merci je suis flatté alors cyril
on a quand même du boulot pourquoi et
mais quand même pour tout ce qui est tu
es tu as vu tu as vu toutes les meufs
toutes ces neuf qu'il se présente contre
toi la
iago des irakiens
a dit d'al gore
me fallait cela joue en mode de jeanne
d'arc en direct de rouen pis toi c'est
chaud bon le programme c'est pas encore
ça va falloir bûcher ouais
on situe là
je veux bâtir une france plus juste
alors c'est hyper gentil mais avant de
bâtir une france plus juste elle
pourrait pas juste finir par ina
bien encore des travaux partout mais je
doute que ce soit fini d'ici avril 2022
infinie déjà ce que tu as dans ton
assiette copie par le nahd et puis il ya
l'autre bah non c'est l'autre la
wii alors elle a repris le flambeau de
son père il paraît que papa voit pas ça
d'un très bon oeil
mais mais mais attention attention cyril
c'est pas le problème ouais parce qu'il
y en a une il y en a une il faut s'en
occuper d'urgence elle a un joli prénom
elles s'appellent sandrine sandrine
rousseau elle est écolo et elle fait sa
rentrée jeudi en primaire eh oui jeudi
c'est le premier tour de la primaire
écologiste l'événement que tout
mais oui et c'est bien simple cet été à
notre dame des landes on ne parlait que
de ça
tu réponds thinon ce qu'ont déjà la
primaire le 16 septembre annonce
en plein milieu de ma détox aura ni noir
ça fait chier c'est le cas de le dire
attention série l'1 qu'on essaye méfie
toi et waddell de sandrine rousseau
parce que ce n'est pas qu'une candidate
c'est l'humoriste qui va
elle ouvre la bouche jeté par terre
derrière c'est plus drôle qu'elle je
vois pas à part peut-être jean castex
alors la semaine dernière elle a fait un
sketch sur jean-pierre belmondo on a
échappé à personne pourquoi pas jean
claude macron un temps poignet je te le
dit cyril si elle n'est pas élue
présidente de la république elle va te
piquer ta place si vous vous tous vous
tous qui nous regardent et si vous aimez
cyril sauver le
voter tous sandrine rousseau à la
primaire écolo imaginez elle lui pique
sa place qu'est ce qui se passe tous les
soirs au lieu de tpm peut honorer quoi
tpmc main touche pas à mon compost
alors par pitié jeudi allaient tous
voter et en a qui sont morts pour que
les écologistes et le droit de vote
votez tous pour sandrine rousseau et
pour tous ceux qui savent toujours pas
qui c'est
petit
bébé mâle blanc
enfin qu'on veut
le permanent c'est comme dans les cordes
nous sommes
aux agents bien même on
avec ses gros sabots celle queen écolo
[Musique]
bakou
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe ben moi je voulais l'invité à
danser
d'abord je voulais savoir si ils avaient
sanctuaire oui je l'avais voit la bomba
très bien on peut donc
après l'émission
vous pouvez vous avez joué à la marraine
c'est la bible ou si vous êtes un accord
votre coiffeur jean claude biguine